[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous demandais de fermer les yeux
pour commencer et demander quelque chose
qui est un comble pour la piste c'est de
respirer donc je vous laisse fermez les
yeux vous relâcher m les bras long du
corps inspirez profondément expiré
inspirez profondément et experts
que dans l'intervention il se peut que
vous soyez un peu en ap alors j'ai une
particularité à il ya quelques petites
particularités dans mon sport c'est que
on est très dans l'autonomie vous allez
découvrir quelque chose qui est assez
assez sympa parce qu'au-delà de au delà
de la performance au delà de tout ce que
cela peut demander en tant que sportif
ça m'a demandé beaucoup d'autonomie de
développement sur moi qui avait un
énorme manque de confiance
ça a été très dur de pouvoir supporter
l'école tous les stress qui était
engendré et à cette pression scolaire
est encore plus haut cet esprit à ce
mental qui fonctionnait tout le temps
pour moi c'était vraiment une locomotive
on était même plutôt de l'ordre de la
fusée en fait il y avait le corps dans
la classe et le reste était dehors donc
ça a été pour moi un énorme changement
et ce changement je le dois à mon sport
alors ça fait un peu classique de
commencer par ce type d'image mais en
même temps également
braye en a qui disent que c'est sûrement
pour séduire les filles mais pas que
alors vous imaginez bien que là je suis
censé me relâcher en apnée statique en
compétition et là je sais pas si vous
vous rendez compte
mais on est un petit peu loin du temple
du bénin à l'intérieur on est plutôt en
boîte de nuit
120 pulsations au repos j'étais très
loin du relâchement chantaient mon coeur
qui tapait à travers la combinaison
ça c'est ma première compétition je
faisais moins deux minutes par rapport à
ce que je faisais à l'entraînement ça
vous donne à peu près le niveau de
stress que j'avais à cette époque là
donc n'ont rien et innés le ne sommes
pas un sport élitiste bien au contraire
des fois il faut passer par toutes les
étapes et j'ai dû malheureusement passer
par des étapes de gestion émotionnelle
de stress qui était très important et
j'ai fait la rencontre d'un préparateur
mental avec qui j'ai travaillé pendant
plus de dix ans
dans un environnement qui est plutôt
originale pour la pratique de l'apnée
entre lac et montagne et en effet même
je peux vous dire que la passion est
très forte parce que vous voyez bien des
stalactites le long du ponton l'eau
était à 5 degrés à ce moment là j'avais
19 ans et comme la découverte de l'apnée
je les fait en corse avec mes parents
c'était il fallait attendre l'été et
j'avais un peu peur du lac jusqu'à l'âge
de 19 ans j'ai décidé d'initier mes
copains même dans l'eau froide les
pauvres qu'est-ce que j'ai dû leur faire
endurer
parce qu'il faut jamais pratiqué les
l'apnée seul bien sûr il faut créer un
environnement et cet environnement il
n'y avait rien bien sûr vous imaginez
bien que des écoles d'apnée à l'époque y
avait pas beaucoup surtout dans la
région et c'est quelque chose qui m'a
poussé à partager mon expérience à
prendre de l'expérience autant sur le
plan pédagogique que sur le plan
justement de là la gestion de soi
arriver à gérer un groupe aussi
puisqu'on m'avait demandé de développer
une section à thonon les bains au bord
du lac léman là où je suis né pour par
la suite
arrivé à annecy en 2011 où j'ai pu me
rendre compte de l'environnement sportif
alors ça vous dresse un petit peu un
topo général et un effet miroir
tout simplement parce que ben quand on
est dans ces situations là on est
vraiment en face de soi même en face de
soi même parce qu'on se retrouve à ce
être en autonomie sans forcément avoir
un coach sans forcément avoir quelqu'un
qui qui sait où vous guider donc vous
êtes obligé de vous voir vous même pour
essayer de travailler sur vous arrivez à
canaliser ses émotions et surtout vous
poser des questions et c'est ça en fait
c'est ce questionnement là où je me
retrouve en face à moi est de me dire
mais qu'est ce qu'il faut que je fasse
pour pouvoir avancer
alors certes j'ai eu des aides mais le
fait d'avancer seul m'a fait avancer un
peu plus vite mais avant tout il faut
que vous sachiez quel est mon activité
parce que dans l'api nice est très large
eh ben mon but est de descendre en
profondeur donc la profondeur vous
imaginez bien que y'a pas que la
profondeur physique
de la mer est également la profondeur de
soi donc je vous emmène avec moi sous
l'eau en immersion
alors
alors ça c'était aux bahamas ceux qui
connaissent c'est le jeans bluehole à
long island une compétition
internationale d'apnée qui se déroule
tous les ans et là je pars sortait d'une
phase un peu difficile mais je devais
arriver quand même à canaliser qu'aziz
mes émotions en surface pour être
vraiment dans l'instant et d'en
ressentir tout simplement parce que je
dois pas aller trop vite j'ai aussi
m'économiser arrive à gérer l'effort
parce qu'il faut quand même percer la
surface descendre mais être dans
l'économie l'effort bien entendu on
annonce une performance avant d'y aller
donc la corde et paramétrer à la
profondeur target qui pour le coup est à
101 m et à ce moment là je dois
progressivement relâchées mon effort
mais toujours être dans la concentration
parce qu'il ya une multitude de choses
techniques à laquelle on doit penser
comme la compensation des oreilles donc
ça nous demande encore plus de
concentration un instant présent
beaucoup me pose la question mais à quoi
tu penses pendant que tu descends
justement on évite de penser
on essaie de percevoir et de ressentir
les choses et tout en se détachant de
l'environnement compétitif ce qui est un
comble puisque en fit don n'y participe
mais au final sans y participer et
accepter cette pression qui s'exerce de
plus en plus profondément qui vient
écraser nos poumons écrasé la
combinaison augmenter la flo la coulée
on axe plus progressivement n'a plus
d'efforts à fournir puisque le corps
s'enfonce dans la mer pourra essayer
d'atteindre un état de relâchement
maximale parce que vous imaginez bien
qu'à cette profondeur la tension est
forte il faut l'accepter et dans un
environnement stressant que ce soit dans
le travail ou dans la vie de tous les
jours ou en profondeur c'est justement
de encore plus atteindre un état de
relâchement jusqu'à arriver à l'objectif
prendre un témoin qui va être comme
quelque chose qui dépend de valider
cette performance en remontant remontent
à la surface
il ya toujours un moment où on atteint
le fond pour pouvoir remonter et grimper
mais il n'ya pas qu'eux il ya en plus de
ça un effet de narcose c'est comme si
vous preniez un show d'alcool agen 3
vers agen d'un coup donc ça vous assomme
un peu vous sentez tout flottant et en
même temps avec plein d'idées qui vous
traverse la tête un véritable tgv de
penser qu'il faut canaliser et pour ça
il faut vraiment être concentré dans
l'instant présent pour être dans
l'efficience d'économie de l'effort et
cette marque aux elle augmente un petit
peu quand on commence à remonter
elle régresse progressivement mais il ya
quand même l'effort physique
l'acide lactique l' envie de respirer
qui vient s'ajouter à tout ça et il faut
garder cette lucidité jusqu'à la surface
donc c'est on est toujours un état de
concentration donc c'est un état de
concentration qu'on essaie d'amener un à
ce qu'on appelle un état de flou dans le
niveau sportif dans le milieu sportif
qui nous permet justement d'arriver à
réaliser ces performances
quel que soit l'environnement stressant
toutes les personnes qui peut vous voir
que sur les médias ce soit votre famille
parce que maintenant on est retransmis
en live
et là il faut valider une performance et
pour ça il faut qu'on enlève les
lunettes on fasse le signe qu'on dise
i'm ok au juge qu'ils analysent notre
capacité de lucidité sur trente secondes
avant de valider la performance donc
c'est jamais fini
il faut aussi garder sa lucidité en
surface et je peux vous assurer c'est
pas si simple quand au bout de l'avenue
avec un manque d'oxygène qu'en plus de
ça on a un peu de narcose et tout ça est
mélangé c'est un espèce de feux
d'artifice ou tout de suite il faut se
reconnecter dans l'instant présent
revenir à la surface le plus rapidement
possible
bien sûr partagé l'élément partager
l'expérience
alors c'est ça la particularité de ce
sport il ya d'autres vont me dire il ya
le saut à la perche c'est qu'on annonce
une performance la veille
alors c'est plutôt original mais c'est
ce qui permet justement d'organiser la
sécurité et aussi de s'engager sur
quelque chose que l'on maîtrise ce qu'on
peut pas annoncer quelque chose de dix
mètres de plus il faut que ce soit en
confiance et c'est surtout prendre de la
confiance pour arriver à prendre la
confiance il faut être dans l'instant
présent développer cet état de
concentration comment on fait et c'est
ça qu'il a fallu travailler ça c'est un
peu l'impression qu'on a quand on arrive
à la surface un peu dans un état de flou
et malgré cet état de flou arrivé à la
gérer les émotions même dans les pires
instants le résultat pendant toute sa
grandeur quand on comprend donc il est
simplement une conséquence du chemin et
non un objectif déterminé
en effet en fait si je devais me
focaliser sur la presse sur la
performance à laquelle j'allais ou sur
la médaille ou sur le résultat je
pourrais pas faire ses performances ce
qui me permet d'atteindre ses objectifs
c'est de me focaliser dans l'instant est
dans l'action plus on est dans l'action
pour une capacité de productivité de
réaliser quelque chose
malheureusement notre système nous
pousse un peu trop peut-être dans le
résultat avant même de nous préoccuper
d'abord de quelles sont les actions
qu'on peut mettre en place bien sûr ces
demandes plein de choses mais surtout au
delà de la force de l'intention qui en
fait toutes nos croyances qui vont
générer notre propre réalité
c'est l'effet magnétique de chaque
pensée qui vont attirer à nous notre
propre réalité
nos relations notre éducation et en fait
il ya quelque chose qui par dessus tout
que j'ai remarqué qu'ils étaient très
forts chez moi qu'il a fallu et faire
évoluer si le verbe chaque mot chaque
mois une vibration chaque mois une
intention et il est très important dans
ce dans d'en prendre conscience
parce que c'est eux qui vont vibrer qui
vont s'incarner en nous et qui vont
créer notre propre intentions ça va
au-delà du sport et des expériences j'en
ai plein dans ce mode là parce que
j'étais dans un langage très négatif
il a fallu transformer sa et cette
transformation a permis d'atteindre les
objectifs sportifs jusqu'à plus de 113
mètres de profondeur et sans avoir
changé ce vocabulaire là j'aurais
peut-être pas pu le faire et on est
témoin mon préparateur mental qui m'a
accompagné à ce moment là sur sur la
plongée et a toujours des questions
existentielles on se dit mais c'est quoi
l'intuition et bien c'est ça des fois on
cherche à expliquer quoi que ce plein de
choses à travers le développement
personnel et au final mais les choses
sont un peu en face de nous c'est plus
on est dans l'instant plus on vit
vraiment pleinement l'instant plus on
utilise nos cinq sens voir sentir
toucher écouter plus on line et
d'incessants cela et plus on va être
capable de percevoir notre environnement
en fait l'intuition c'est une
information qui vient de l'extérieur et
en fait on est obligé d'être dans la
résidence et dans la capacité d'accepter
ce qui se passe autour et pour le faire
il faut être dans une capacité
d'adaptation et c'est l'intuition qu'il
veut aussi nous le permettre de fin qui
va nous permettre d'accéder à ces
choses-là eia qu'il ya un élément qui
est très fort que dont je me souvenais
steam est complètement mon frère est
passionné par la par l'eau c'est un
fervent défenseur de lacs et des
rivières avec lequel j'ai rejoint pour
faire un projet vidéo web série et on
est entouré par l'eau dans la famille
mais pas coeur en fête
j'imaginais bien qu'il ya l'eau à
l'extérieur mais aussi à l'eau à
l'intérieur on est tous composés d'eau
et il ya quelque chose qui est très fort
dans l'eau c'est que tout vibre beaucoup
plus vite
tout rentre en vibration de manière très
très rapide c'est instantané un bruit de
baleines à quatre kilomètres on sait pas
s'il est derrière devant nous à côté
ici je vous dit que votre verbe vos
intentions et vous pensiez ont un impact
sur votre eau eh ben elle résonne 700
plus vite dans votre corps manière
instantanée chaque pensée s'imprégna
nous peut-être la clé de
l'automédication de notre capacité à
nous transformer à nous transcender
il ya quelque chose qui est toujours
existé depuis toujours et dans chaque
civilisation à l'origine c'est pas
nouveau en fête et pas newedge
c'est la méditation et la méditation on
n'est pas obligé de rester le cul sur un
rocher pendant une heure et oui on peut
aussi le faire de manière active
progressivement c'est comme si on essaye
d'améliorer les choses c'est soit pour
diminuer notre consommation dans la
poubelle ben on va diminuer
progressivement notre consommation a
mené 2 - dans moins de déchets
plastiques progressivement la méditation
c'est pareil on va commencer doucement
par se lever le matin et c'est le
médecin jean ans en conscience faire
couler son café faire la cuisine en
conscience versez la douche sur le
visage essayez de percevoir et de
ressentir l'eau qui coule c'est des
choses qui sont anodines mais en fait
qu'on peut faire à n'importe quel moment
on n'est pas obligé de décréter du temps
pour l'invitation la méditation et tout
le temps on doit être tous temps dans
l'es7 état de présence et au final on
n'a pas besoin d'aller plus loin puisque
l'information réside dans le moment
présent et c'est là on est créateur
c'est là on peut créer le plus de choses
et il ya une phrase qui a changé ma vie
c'est observer le penseur si vous
observez vos pensées si vous observez de
vous de l'intérieur vous pensez ce que
vous faites vous êtes capable de
progresser beaucoup plus vite pour bien
sûr être et devenir
j'ai appuyé un peu vite
renversons ensemble chances de choses
vous propose cette fois-ci de partager
cette expérience avec votre entourage
puisque je pense que c'est l'avenir de
demain avec un vrai tournant on a des
intervenants à incroyable qui vont
permettre aussi de prendre conscience de
ces choses là et le fait de mettre la
conscience au coeur va peut-être nous
permettre d'accélérer les choses merci à
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]